you can live on six hours sleep so you
have 18 hours
you have 18 goddamn hours I want to know
what you're doing with your 18 hours
because you can work your 9 to 5 and X 9
and you can travel for an hour here and
there respect
nice little solid commute oh you want to
be a family man love them talk you can
spend 2 hours with your kids what are
you doing with those other five hours
you're watching house of [ __ ] cards
you're playing Madden you're relaxing
than the other intense tennis Gary I
already spent 11 hours well great then
don't complain or want more respect that
by getting rest and dissing that you
were giving up opportunity to go into a
new work you want the audacity to have a
1% life let's let's call what it is you
want to live as well as the 1 to 2
percent in the world it's not very
complicated the map is very wrong
like you if you want to have one of the
best lifes in the world which is you
live on your terms and you have to pay
your dues to get there and you have to
be lucky enough to figure out that you
had talent in the thing that you
actually want to do because you can work
24 hours a day and if you stink at golf
or you're not a good content producer or
you're low those look like the [ __ ] I
would make then you're going to lose so
that's what you got it
[Music]
ah
[Music]